ahora quiero enseñarles una habilidad
manual muy útil que pueden usar cuando
tienen voltajes que lucen como
exponenciales vamos a hablar sobre esta
curva exponencial de aquí que es
generada como parte de una respuesta
natural de este circuito rc encontramos
que el voltaje que pasa a través de aquí
este voltaje vedete en el capacitor su
respuesta natural es igual a de 0 por el
ala menos t / rc este valor de 0 es el
voltaje inicial que proporciona nuestra
fuente de entrada que baja
inmediatamente a 0 y entonces este
circuito hace su respuesta natural vamos
a tener una corriente que sale de este
capacitor que va a viajar en círculo y
esa será la respuesta natural de este
circuito rc vamos a ver las propiedades
de esta función de aquí ya que tiene
propiedades interesantes vamos a
escribirlas aquí de 0 por el ala menos d
sobre rc
lo primero que notamos es que este valor
de 0 es este valor de acá aquí tenemos
de 0 y en esta gráfica particular de 0
es igual a un bolt que fue el voltaje
original ahora veamos este punto de acá
justo cuando llegamos a t igual a 0 la
corriente comienza a bajar conocemos su
altura es desde cero y ahora lo que
quiero saber es cuál es la pendiente en
este punto la pendiente de una curva es
la derivada de esa curva evaluada en
este tiempo de igual a cero encontremos
la derivada de nuestra función de aquí
es de bt v0 por el ala menos t / rc y
esto es igual a de 0 y está menos 1 / rc
baja por el ala menos t / rc ésta es la
derivada de esta exponencial para todo
el tiempo ahora la vamos a evaluar en t
igual a 0 y nos queda que b 0 / rc
con signo negativo y es a la aquí
tenemos 0 en lugar de t por lo que es
a la 0 y a la 0 es 1 y esto es igual a
la pendiente cuando el tiempo es igual a
así que este es el valor de la pendiente
aquí así es como luce está pendiente la
línea tangente a la curva lo siguiente
que voy a hacer es tomar esta línea y
extenderla hacia abajo hasta que cruce
el eje horizontal el eje del tiempo y la
siguiente pregunta que nos vamos a hacer
es cuál es este punto de aquí vamos a
hacer más espacio
ahora tenemos una línea y la ecuación de
la línea es igual a la pendiente por x +
b b es la intersección con el eje del
voltaje m es la pendiente y vamos a
sustituir los valores de nuestra gráfica
y es el eje del voltaje conocemos la
pendiente que es esta menos de 0 / rc lo
multiplicamos por el tiempo y sumamos la
intersección con el eje del voltaje que
sabemos
es de 0 y ahora lo que quiero encontrar
es en qué momento del tiempo el voltaje
es igual a 0 para esta línea anaranjada
así que sustituimos 0 en los voltajes y
vamos a calcular cuál es el tiempo así
que 0 es igual a b 0 por 1 / rc y no nos
olvidemos del signo negativo por t más 1
y si dividimos ambos lados entre b 0 nos
queda que 0 es igual a menos 1 / rc por
t más 1 y queremos despejar a t así que
pasamos al 1 del otro lado y lo
multiplicamos todo por rc el primer paso
es menos 1 igual a menos 1 / rc por t y
al final nos quedamos que t es igual a r
por c
r es este tiempo de aquí es la cantidad
de segundos después del escalón en la
que esta línea toca al eje horizontal y
noten que aquí no tenemos nada debe cero
no hay de cero lo dividimos aquí en uno
de nuestros pasos anteriores así que
independientemente de qué tan alto
comience esto puede ser más alto o más
bajo la pendiente de esta línea siempre
toca al eje horizontal cuando el tiempo
es igual a r porsche y una cosa más que
queremos encontrar es cuando el tiempo
es igual a r por c cuál será el valor de
la exponencial cual es éste voltaje de
aquí cuando el tiempo es igual a r
porsche vamos a usar de nuevo nuestra
ecuación para encontrarlo si regresamos
a la ecuación de d igual a 0 por el ala
menos t / rc en esta ocasión vamos a
sustituir rc en lugar del tiempo y así
encontrar el valor de b
así que b es igual a b 0 x
a menos que queramos que era igual
aguirre por ser / rc o lo que es lo
mismo b es igual a b 0 por el ala menos
1 el valor de es aproximadamente igual a
2.7 y el valor de 1 / es aproximadamente
igual a 0.37 otra forma de decirlo es
que es igual al 37% así que al final
este voltaje de aquí es el 37% de de 0
así que aquí tenemos un par de cosas que
tenemos que tener en nuestra mente el
tiempo que le lleva a esta línea tocar
el eje horizontal el eje del tiempo y es
igual a rc y si quiero conocer el valor
de donde se encuentra la exponencial
cuando el tiempo es igual a rc estará
aproximadamente al 37 por ciento del
valor de cero del valor en donde
comenzamos estas son las ideas básicas y
en el siguiente vídeo les mostraré cómo
usar estas ideas básicas para dibujar
exponenciales muy